This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit, and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details of McDonald's.ca. Atmcatholic.ca.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。全新的红牛龙莓和热带莓能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市，采用冷冻干燥水果制成，带来爆发性的电感风味。全新的红牛能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市。本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，详情请见McDonald's.ca。Atmcatholic.ca。
I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle.
我在囚禁中幸存了九个月，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在那些本应摧毁他们的事情中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会与那些经历过不可思议之事的人们在一起，他们曾被绑架、跟踪、控制，并几乎被剥夺了发声的权利。这些故事讲述了如何才能活着走出来。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享作为女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个陌生人提议让我搭他的摩托车。
I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your for you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island to serve the same level of discourse.
我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以先说“是”，而无需先征求任何人的意见。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性来换取怜悯。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。如果您的书架和您的“推荐”页面对您的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。《Pro Society》是一个每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合那些认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》值得同等程度讨论的人。
Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecology at the Adria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. 100% of women go through menopause.
每周，我们都会与您最喜爱的作家、图书博主以及大量深思熟虑的观点一起，将书籍、互联网和流行文化联系起来。是的，我着迷了。我着迷了。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。欢迎来到《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特博士，纽约阿德里亚健康研究所女性健康与妇科系主任。我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，并将关于中年女性健康的重要信息直接带给您。100%的女性都会经历更年期。
Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Help with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Speak and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here. back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we are talking about time, specifically why it seems to move so much faster as we get older and why the months just seem to be shorter and shorter every single year. I want you to think back for a second to being a kid and to being a kid in summer. Like those summers used to feel absolutely endless. You'd go back to school
即使这是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它呢？请在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·波因特博士的《解码女性健康》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯皮克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能在这里。回到另一集，我们当然要剖析20多岁的心理。今天我们谈论的是时间，特别是为什么随着年龄的增长，时间似乎过得快得多，以及为什么每一年月份似乎都变得越来越短。我想让你回想一下小时候，回想一下小时候的夏天。那些夏天曾经感觉绝对是无止境的。你会回到学校
and it felt like a lifetime had passed. Three months felt like eternity. Every six months, you felt like you were a new person. Compare that to now where an entire year can go by and you will swear it's been a couple of weeks. Where did that endless feeling kind of go? Where did it disappear to? I think a lot of us can point to a very specific moment
感觉就像过了一辈子。三个月感觉就像永恒。每六个月，你都觉得你是一个新的人。与现在相比，整整一年过去了，你会发誓才过了几周。那种无止境的感觉去哪儿了？它消失到哪里去了？我想我们很多人都能指出一个非常具体的时刻
where our relationship with time kind of broke. And that's probably during COVID. Suddenly, our days had no shade. There was no commute, no plans, no real distinction between a Tuesday and a Saturday. And for a lot of us, especially anyone who was a teenager in the early 20s at the time, I think months just kind of dissolved into each other. And I don't think many of us have fully gotten that sense of structured, meaningful time back. The days just get faster and faster.
我们与时间的关系破裂了。那可能是在新冠疫情期间。突然间，我们的日子没有了阴影。没有通勤，没有计划，周二和周六之间没有真正的区别。对于我们很多人来说，特别是当时20出头的青少年，我认为月份只是融化在一起了。我不认为我们很多人完全找回了那种结构化、有意义的时间感。日子过得越来越快。
So today, we are going to actually unpack this. Why does time feel like it speeds up as we get older? And how do we slow it right back down again using actual psychology and actual science? We're going to talk about the different types of time, the ways that time can be measured, especially how they are understood across cultures, how memory and novelty play into all of this, how being online, our digital lives have changed our perception of time. And then, most importantly, is promised the three things that will make your life and your days and your years feel longer without you happening to do very much at all. So without further ado, let's get into it.
所以今天，我们实际上要拆解这一点。为什么随着年龄的增长，时间感觉过得更快？我们如何利用实际的心理学和科学让它慢下来？我们将讨论不同类型的时间，衡量时间的方式，特别是它们在不同文化中是如何被理解的，记忆和新奇感如何影响这一切，在线生活、数字生活如何改变了我们对时间的感知。然后，最重要的是，承诺的三件事将使你的生活、你的日子和你的年份感觉更长，而无需你做太多事情。所以事不宜迟，让我们开始吧。
So in order to really start answering questions about time passing us by with age and why that feels faster, we do need to understand how time is even measured in the first place. And I know it feels silly and quite obvious to ask things like, you know, what is time? It's very like, philosophical because I feel like we all kind of know it's something ingrained in us very deeply, but there are levels to this. There's always levels to things like this. Your sense of time originates in the brain. Different regions keep track of different aspects of your environment that anchor your time perception. For example, things like daylight, things like exhaustion, things like movement, attention. Interestingly, the evidence suggests that there may
因此，为了真正开始回答关于时间随年龄流逝以及为什么感觉更快的问题，我们确实需要了解时间是如何被衡量的。我知道问“什么是时间”之类的问题感觉很傻，也很明显。这非常哲学，因为我觉得我们都知道它是深深植根于我们内心的东西，但这是有层次的。像这样的事情总是有层次的。你的时间感源于大脑。不同的区域跟踪你环境中锚定你时间感知的不同方面。例如，日光、疲劳、运动、注意力等事物。有趣的是，证据表明可能
be a separate clock for each of our senses and that they all kind of talk and coordinate and communicate to just give us a sense of where we are in a day, where we are in a moment where we are in our lives. Based on what you are experiencing, time can either dilate and feel like it's passing slower, like when you're bored, or it can contract and feel like it's speeding up, like when you're in a flow state or when you're in a really good conversation or you're drunk and you're partying and suddenly it's 2 a.m. All of this is based in your brain. So the neurological experience of time is one thing. Then there is the social experience or social measurement of time, which is a lot more critical for what we're talking about today. Things like morning, like noon,
每个感官都有一个单独的时钟，它们都在交谈、协调和沟通，只是为了让我们知道我们在一天中的位置，我们在一个时刻的位置，我们在生活中的位置。根据你的经历，时间要么会膨胀，感觉过得更慢，比如当你无聊时；要么会收缩，感觉过得更快，比如当你处于心流状态，或者当你进行一场非常好的谈话，或者你喝醉了在聚会，突然就凌晨2点了。所有这些都基于你的大脑。所以时间的神经学体验是一回事。然后是时间的社会体验或社会衡量，这对于我们今天讨论的内容更为关键。比如早晨、中午、
like bedtime, 2 p.m., lunchtime, midnight. That is what we would call the stand. measurement of time or the social measurement of time. However, the typical units of measurement that we use, so minutes, seconds, weeks, years, that kind of stuff, they're just made up. They're made up. We just use them to communicate and get on the same page. At some point, someone decided 60 seconds made a minute, 60 minutes made an hour, simply because it was very easy to divide. That's like the one theory. It was an easily divisible number. That's why it was chosen. Measure time is therefore what we call a social construct, and how time feels to us beyond that, psychologically, is also very cultural. So historically, and now we're really getting into the
睡前、下午2点、午餐时间、午夜。这就是我们所说的标准时间衡量或社会时间衡量。然而，我们使用的典型衡量单位，即分钟、秒、周、年等，都是编造的。它们是编造的。我们只是用它们来交流并达成共识。在某个时候，有人决定60秒是一分钟，60分钟是一小时，仅仅因为它很容易除尽。这就是一种理论。它是一个容易除尽的数字。这就是它被选择的原因。因此，衡量时间是我们所说的社会建构，而在此之外，心理上时间对我们感觉如何，也是非常文化的。所以从历史上看，现在我们真的要进入
history here, but time has been measured differently by different cultures. Kind of makes sense, but agricultural societies used to measure time by changing seasons and crop rotations. Others went by like the position of the sun and the moon. That's what led to the invention of the sundial, the first like original kind of clock measurement of time. Interestingly, there is an anthropologist. His name is Edward T. Hall. And he argued that Western societies, we see time is fixed and perpetual, which is why we like to think about things sequentially and chronologically. And we really like ideas of progress and we like ideas of growth. And our behaviors and timelines are shaped by this experience and how we see time as kind of the segmented thing that moves forward. On the other hand,
历史了，但时间在不同文化中被衡量的方式不同。这很有道理，但农业社会过去通过变化的季节和作物轮作来衡量时间。其他人则通过太阳和月亮的位置。这就是导致日晷发明的原因，这是第一种原始的时间衡量方式。有趣的是，有一位人类学家。他的名字是爱德华·T·霍尔。他认为西方社会将时间视为固定和永恒的，这就是为什么我们喜欢顺序和按时间顺序思考事物。我们非常喜欢进步和增长的想法。我们的行为和时间表是由这种体验以及我们如何将时间视为一种向前移动的分割事物所塑造的。另一方面，
he and his kind of research and travels saw how other societies like those in Latin America and those in Asia are what we call polychronic, meaning time is viewed more as a stream that ebbs and flows. A lot can happen all at once and then they can be nothing for years. Nothing for years. I also came across this writing by the Kenyan-born philosopher John M. B.T. and he notes how Kenyan belief specifically doesn't conceptualize the future at all. Because in his view, time needs to be, well, not in his view, in their view, time needs to be experienced in order to be real. So future time is not a concept. Since it's impossible to experience the future, like, it just doesn't exist. Instead, like, you need, the future is only created by
他和他的研究及旅行见证了其他社会，如拉丁美洲和亚洲的社会，是如何被称为多时性的，这意味着时间被视为一种起伏的流。很多事情可以同时发生，然后可能几年什么都没有。几年什么都没有。我还读到了肯尼亚出生的哲学家约翰·M·B·T的著作，他指出肯尼亚的信仰体系根本没有未来的概念。因为在他看来，时间需要被体验才能成为真实的。所以未来时间不是一个概念。既然不可能体验未来，它就不存在。相反，你需要，未来只能由
the present moment. And you have to see how that perception that's passed along culturally, will influence how people view the future and how people view planning and how people view death and all these sorts of things. So as we've evolved, we've definitely tried to get more specific and unified across different locations and different cultures, especially for capitalism, especially for the purpose of trade. And that is why we kind of invented standard time zones. And that's why we invented coordinated universal time, where we kind of all, we can kind of know what time it is in Sydney versus what time in London versus Kenya. Despite that, each of us will still experience time differently. Our perception of time is very unique. It varies from person to person,
当下时刻创造。你必须看到这种文化传递的感知将如何影响人们看待未来的方式，以及人们如何看待计划、死亡以及所有这些事情。随着我们的进化，我们绝对试图在不同地点和不同文化中变得更加具体和统一，特别是为了资本主义，特别是为了贸易的目的。这就是为什么我们发明了标准时区。这就是为什么我们发明了协调世界时，我们可以知道悉尼、伦敦和肯尼亚的时间。尽管如此，我们每个人仍然会以不同的方式体验时间。我们对时间的感知是非常独特的。它因人而异，
regardless of what the time on a clock or on your phone says. Ten minutes to me might not feel the same as it does to you or the next person, even if it's measured the same way. It depends on what we have going on. It depends on how we mark time personally. For example, do you mark time by big moments or novel moments or sleep or productivity or days. It changes if we're listening to music. It changes if we're in a flow state. And it just changes because of other overarching personality factors like patience levels, temperament, even how you were raised.
无论时钟或手机上的时间怎么说。对我来说十分钟可能和你或下一个人感觉不一样，即使它的衡量方式相同。这取决于我们正在做什么。这取决于我们如何个人化地标记时间。例如，你是通过重大时刻、新奇时刻、睡眠、生产力还是天数来标记时间？如果我们正在听音乐，它会改变。如果我们处于心流状态，它会改变。它也会因为其他总体人格因素而改变，比如耐心水平、气质，甚至你是如何被抚养长大的。
And this is the third face of time, the one that stems from your own psychology and your own experiences. And the one that we really need to explore to kind of understand, why time feels so much faster now than it did when we were little kids or than it did when we were in COVID. One thing that we know really influences our perception of time, more than anything else, is novelty. Basically, novelty is the more new things you experience, the more newness you have in your life. The more of that, the more that those long stretches of time are broken up by things that kind of create distinct snapshots.
这是时间的第三个面，源于你自己的心理和经历。我们需要探索它，以理解为什么时间现在感觉比我们小时候或新冠疫情期间快得多。我们知道的一件事确实影响了我们对时间的感知，比任何其他事物都更重要，那就是新奇感。基本上，新奇感就是你经历的新事物越多，你生活中的新鲜感就越多。越多，那些漫长的时间段就被那些创造出独特快照的事物所分割。
know I said that time seems to speed up when we're really interested in something or when we're having a lot of fun or we're curious or we're excited, but those moments in hindsight seem to make time feel more expansive. So in the moment novelty speeds up time in hindsight, it actually slows it down. It makes it seem like you have more of it. In a 2007 study published in the Journal of Vision, researchers found that when people were exposed to two types of stimulus, one which was exciting and large and colorful and flashing, and one which was very simple and slightly boring, people thought that they saw the first stimulus, the exciting one, for longer, despite seeing both the boring and the exciting one for the exact same period of time. Remember, the researchers
我知道我说过，当我们对某事非常感兴趣，或者当我们玩得很开心、好奇或兴奋时，时间似乎会加速，但回想起来，这些时刻似乎让时间感觉更广阔。所以，在当下，新奇感会加速时间；在回顾时，它实际上会减慢时间。它让你觉得你拥有更多的时间。在2007年发表在《视觉杂志》上的一项研究中，研究人员发现，当人们接触到两种类型的刺激时，一种是令人兴奋、巨大、多彩且闪烁的，另一种是非常简单且略显无聊的，人们认为他们看到第一种刺激（令人兴奋的那种）的时间更长，尽管他们看到无聊和令人兴奋的刺激的时间完全相同。记住，研究人员
were controlling this. So this kind of proves this point that novelty seems to make time feel bigger, more is kind of crammed into the same amount of space that, you know, wouldn't be as filled with boring things. Further to this, there is a very, very famous experimental study and also an experimental method called the Oddball Experiment, which has kind of proven something very similar. So the Oddball experiment is this protocol where during the experiment, people are shown images over and over in the same order, but at one point there is a novel kind of odd-ball image thrown into the mix. People reported perceiving this new image as being shown for a much longer period of time, similar to the study from before. And this has been repeated time and time again.
正在控制这一点。所以这证明了新奇感似乎让时间感觉更大，更多的东西被塞进了同样的空间里，而这些空间如果充满了无聊的事情就不会那么充实。此外，有一个非常、非常著名的实验研究，也是一种实验方法，叫做“怪球实验”，它已经证明了类似的事情。所以“怪球实验”是一种协议，在实验过程中，人们一遍又一遍地以相同的顺序看到图像，但在某个时刻，混合中会加入一个新奇的“怪球”图像。人们报告说，感知到这个新图像显示的时间要长得多，类似于之前的研究。这已经被反复重复了。
It's one of the most repeated studies, and it essentially shows that time seems to stretch and seems to get larger, the more that we are experiencing that is new to us. This is really critical, and this is why time appears to go faster the older we get. When we are younger, we are We are experiencing new things all the time, all the time, whether it's our first time learning about a concept in school or hearing a word or our first time riding a bike or seeing a new species of flower or trying a new food. There's just so much stuff to see and to feel and to hear. We are constantly being exposed to new stuff.
这是最常被重复的研究之一，它本质上表明，我们经历的新事物越多，时间似乎就越拉伸，似乎就变得越大。这一点非常关键，这就是为什么我们越老，时间似乎过得越快。当我们年轻时，我们一直在经历新事物，无论是我们第一次在学校学习一个概念，还是听到一个词，或者我们第一次骑自行车，看到一种新的花卉，或者尝试一种新的食物。有太多的东西要看、要感受、要听。我们不断地接触到新东西。
As we age though, there are just fewer and fewer things that we perceive as entirely new because the more life you have lived, the more you have encountered, hopefully. And this is what causes the change in our perception. And that is definitely applicable in our 20s. And we probably notice it more here than any other decade. If you think about it, our lives become a lot more structured during this decade, especially around work, especially around full-time work. And it can feel very tedious and monotonous.
然而，随着年龄的增长，我们感知为全新的事物越来越少，因为你活得越久，你遇到的就越多，希望如此。这就是导致我们感知变化的原因。这绝对适用于我们的20多岁。我们可能在这里比在任何其他十年中都更注意到这一点。如果你想一想，我们的生活在这个十年中变得更加结构化，特别是在工作方面，特别是在全职工作方面。它可能会让人感到非常乏味和单调。
And this is why time seems to speed up. very quickly after we leave school. When we were at school, we had more vacation time. We were always learning different subjects. We had a lot more space for new experiences, specifically during our every day. Now we are normally focused in doing the exact same thing. That's what a full-time job sometimes feels like. So time seems to get faster. Memory is also a big part of this conversation because our perception of time is not only limited to the present, but to the past, the present, and the future. Just like there are different types of time, you know, there's the social construct, there's the psychological construct, there are also different types of memory. These include
这就是为什么时间在离开学校后似乎过得非常快。当我们上学时，我们有更多的假期。我们一直在学习不同的科目。我们在日常生活中有了更多的空间来体验新事物。现在我们通常专注于做完全相同的事情。这就是全职工作有时给人的感觉。所以时间似乎变快了。记忆也是这场对话的重要组成部分，因为我们对时间的感知不仅限于现在，还限于过去、现在和未来。就像有不同类型的时间，你知道，有社会建构，有心理建构，也有不同类型的记忆。这些包括
things like episodic memory, which is all about our own personal memories and our own personal collections of important moments for us. There's semantic memory, which is about facts and like general knowledge. There's procedural memory, which is automatic processes, like knowing how to ride a bike, the classic one, you know, how to think when you're typing on a keyboard, that's procedural memory. There's short-term memory or working memory. There's sensory memory. And then there is perspective memory, which is basically remembering to do something in the future. Like I say to myself, okay, I need to get groceries tonight. Later on, my memory is going to remind me, hopefully. When we are looking back on certain periods of life with fondness or maybe with pain or
情景记忆，它完全关于我们自己的个人记忆和我们个人收集的重要时刻。语义记忆，关于事实和一般知识。程序性记忆，是自动过程，比如知道如何骑自行车，经典的例子，你知道，打字时如何思考，那是程序性记忆。短期记忆或工作记忆。感觉记忆。然后是前瞻记忆，基本上是记住在未来做某事。比如我对自己说，好吧，我今晚需要去买杂货。稍后，我的记忆会提醒我，希望如此。当我们带着喜爱或痛苦回顾人生的某些时期时，或者
nostalgia, we're delving into episodic memory. And the reason time felt slower in the past is because we are relying on memories that feel more distinct and segmented or chapter like. And because past times in your life, we're once more filled with increased novelty compared to what you're experiencing right now. They stand out, which probably, you know, right now probably feels very same same. In hindsight, though, what you might find is that actually this feels quite different when it's relative to other things that you've experienced. There's another really interesting layer here, which is emotion. Emotion determines what gets remembered and how time feels. We don't necessarily remember the happiest moments the most clearly. We remember the most emotionally
怀旧，我们正在深入研究情景记忆。过去时间感觉更慢的原因是我们依赖于感觉更独特、更分段或像章节一样的记忆。而且因为你生命中的过去时光，与你现在正在经历的相比，曾经充满了更多的新奇感。它们脱颖而出，这可能，你知道，现在可能感觉非常千篇一律。然而，回想起来，你可能会发现，实际上当它相对于你经历过的其他事情时，这感觉相当不同。这里还有另一个非常有趣的层面，那就是情感。情感决定了什么被记住以及时间感觉如何。我们不一定最清楚地记得最快乐的时刻。我们记得最情绪化
significant ones because our brain yells out at us that those are the most important ones. If you are experiencing fear or excitement or awe or embarrassment or social rejection, even love, your brain is like, this really matters. This felt really, really intense. Save this. That is why emotionally intense periods of your life often feel longer in hindsight. You know, when you're falling in love, in the few months of like, the few months after you're grieving, time you've spent away on your gap year, like just the intensity of those first few months at university, those all kind of stick out to me. It's the emotional significance around those that strengthens memory consolidation because there's also more emo diversity. There's different
重要的时刻，因为我们的大脑向我们大喊，那些是最重要的。如果你正在经历恐惧、兴奋、敬畏、尴尬或社会排斥，甚至爱，你的大脑会觉得，这真的很重要。这感觉非常、非常强烈。保存这个。这就是为什么你生命中情绪强烈的时期回想起来往往感觉更长。你知道，当你坠入爱河时，在悲伤后的几个月里，你在间隔年里度过的时间，就像大学头几个月的强度，那些对我来说都历历在目。正是围绕这些的情感意义加强了记忆巩固，因为也有更多的情绪多样性。有不同的
feelings all happening at once that give layers to this memory, give it complexity, and basically give us more material to think back on and to reconstruct later. All of this, combined has a name. This whole thing we're talking about has a term. It's called the memory paradox of time. All we're trying to say is time isn't measured by a clock. It is measured by what you remember and what is consolidated and what is not and what your emotional state was at the time. And it's influenced by so many things that we don't think about. We don't think about our emotions and how they influence time or our mental state or our personality or newness. That's why you could have two people and they could both live to 75 years old. And we're
感受同时发生，给这段记忆增加了层次，增加了复杂性，基本上给了我们更多的材料来回想并在以后重构。所有这些结合在一起有一个名字。我们谈论的整个事情有一个术语。它被称为时间的记忆悖论。我们想说的是，时间不是由时钟衡量的。它是由你记住的东西、被巩固的东西、没有被巩固的东西以及你当时的情绪状态来衡量的。它受到我们没有想到的许多事情的影响。我们没有想到我们的情绪以及它们如何影响时间，或者我们的心理状态、个性或新鲜感。这就是为什么你可以有两个人，他们都可以活到75岁。而我们
and one person could feel like their time on earth probably equated more to 50 years, one person could feel like their time equated to 100. Time is just not the same for all of us based on how we fill it. Okay, we're going to take a short break here, but when we return, let's talk about the impact of the pandemic, shall we, and lockdowns and social media. And why, for those of us specifically in our 20s, we are perceiving time as faster than maybe any other generation. So stay with us. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with
一个人可能会觉得他们在地球上的时间可能更等同于50年，一个人可能会觉得他们的时间等同于100年。时间对我们所有人来说并不相同，这取决于我们如何填充它。好吧，我们在这里休息一下，但当我们回来时，让我们谈谈大流行的影响，好吗，还有封锁和社交媒体。以及为什么，对于我们这些20多岁的人来说，我们感知时间比任何其他一代人都要快。所以请留下来。全新的红牛龙莓和热带莓能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市，采用
freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details at McDonald's.com. At participating Canadian restaurants excluding Quebec. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people
冷冻干燥水果制成，带来爆发性的电感风味。全新的红牛能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市。本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，详情请见McDonald's.com。在参与活动的加拿大餐厅，魁北克除外。在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享作为女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个陌生人提议让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以先说“是”，而无需先征求任何人的意见。我的使命是重新定义“solita”这个词，用可能性来换取怜悯。每次我试图独处时，我都会遇到人
and they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything.
他们会说，你对我们笑了。这里没多少人笑。当你独处时，你对世界的感知最敏锐，而不是被灌输关于它的谎言。这可以是一个你突破极限、改变主意或唤醒新自我的时间。所以无论你是独自旅行的老手，还是太紧张而不敢预订第一次旅行，我希望你在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。当我14岁时，我被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我幸存了下来，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在那些本应摧毁他们的事情中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边那个低沉、嘲弄的声音说，闭嘴，什么都别说。
Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was something. someone at the end of my bed and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
每周，我都会与那些经历过不可思议之事的人们在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始感觉到有什么东西。有人在我的床尾，我开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，并几乎被剥夺了发声的权利。但这些不是关于他们被夺走什么的故事。这是关于如何才能活着走出来的故事。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》，
or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table.
或您获取播客的任何地方。如果您的书架和您的“推荐”页面对您的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《Pro Society》，每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合思想的女儿们、流行文化痴迷者，以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》值得同等程度讨论的人。我是伊丽·拉洛，每周我们都会将书籍、互联网和每个人都无法停止谈论的对话联系起来。我得去查查这个故事。我着迷了。我着迷了。从畅销书作家和你最喜欢的图书博主到最新的流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可以讨论的。
It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. Hey, what's up? I'm Tony Gonzalez. And I'm October Gonzalez.
就像如果你能在引人入胜的角色中隐藏一些真实的信息，那么这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度解析、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢思考太多的读者社区，你都来对地方了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。在书页间见。嘿，你好吗？我是托尼·冈萨雷斯。我是奥克托芭·冈萨雷斯。
But you can call me Toby. We want you to join us. us on our new podcast, No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez. We get real about marriage, parenthood, sex, divorce, and all the nitty-gritty stuff we all think about, but just don't say out loud. I hate that job. You're probably just going to meet with some rich guy and he's going to whisk you away and I'll never see you again.
但你可以叫我托比。我们希望你加入我们。在我们的新播客《No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez》中。我们真实地谈论婚姻、为人父母、性、离婚以及我们都想过但只是没有大声说出来的所有琐碎细节。我讨厌那份工作。你可能只是去见某个有钱人，他会把你带走，我再也见不到你了。
Would you say a D-less actor? D? I don't even know. There's such thing as D. No, no, no. I mean, like... I can't even get on the C-list. Like, I'm not even an average.
你会说一个D级演员吗？D？我甚至不知道。有D级这种东西吗？不，不，不。我的意思是，像……我甚至无法进入C级。就像，我甚至不是平均水平。
I'm not even passing. I'm failing. Listen to No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez, part of My Culture Podcast Network, available on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When it comes to thinking about why time feels different for people our age compared to our parents or even to younger generations, two things, two big things stand out. I've said the first one a couple of times. It's the pandemic.
我甚至没有及格。我失败了。请收听《No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez》，这是My Culture播客网络的一部分，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当谈到为什么我们这个年龄的人感觉时间与我们的父母甚至年轻一代不同时，两件事，两件大事脱颖而出。我已经说了好几次第一件事了。那就是大流行。
I'm not going to make too many sweeping generalizations about how old I think you are because I know there's a couple of like 60 year olds, 30 year olds, even like 15 year olds who are listening. Actually, a lot of people that listen aren't in their 20s, but I know a big chunk of you are. And if you were between the ages of 17 and 25 during COVID, a big chunk of those memory making years for you and experiences that were associated with those years, like, they just can't be replicated and they didn't happen. You know, those things that were meant to happen to you at 21, they never did. You were indoors. You were inside. Things like solo travel and exchange programs and graduations and orientation weeks and trips and, you know, time spent with friends before
我不会对你认为你多大年纪做出太多笼统的概括，因为我知道有几个60岁、30岁，甚至15岁的人在听。实际上，很多听众并不在20多岁，但我知道你们中的很大一部分是。如果你在新冠疫情期间年龄在17到25岁之间，那些记忆形成年份中的很大一部分，以及与这些年份相关的经历，它们无法被复制，而且它们没有发生。你知道，那些本应在你21岁时发生的事情，它们从未发生。你在室内。你在里面。像独自旅行、交流项目、毕业典礼、迎新周、旅行，以及，你知道，在每个人都有全职工作之前与朋友共度的时间，
everybody got a full-time job. Like, the opportunity for these things kind of feels like it came and went. And so you're missing this big chunk of years that weren't distinct, that weren't impressionable. And we're mainly, if we're being on a spent scrolling TikTok, like during this massive period of your life when you were meant to be going out and having all these experiences, that just didn't happen for you. And it's very easy to feel like that time passed. That time just was like a weird frozen state that we can't get back. It's also no surprise that the rise of social media, and specifically TikTok, like TikTok took
这些事情的机会感觉就像来了又走了。所以你错过了这一大段不独特、不令人印象深刻的岁月。如果我们诚实的话，我们大部分时间都在刷TikTok，在你本应出去经历所有这些事情的生命中的这个巨大时期，这些事情并没有为你发生。感觉时间流逝非常容易。那段时间就像一个奇怪的冻结状态，我们无法找回。社交媒体的兴起，特别是TikTok，TikTok在这一时期起飞，这也不足为奇，
off during this period of time, and it only sped up our perception of time on top of the fact that we weren't experiencing as much novelty as we had before. The introduction of short form infinite scroll videos has drastically changed how people of our generation are experiencing time compared to older people, probably second only to the pandemic. We began this episode by kind of exploring the three types of time, the measured, the social and the perceived. In this day, age, researchers are now saying there's a fourth, and that is the digital experience of time. And it has completely flipped everything we know about time on its head. As digital technology has advanced to the point where I would say everybody has a smartphone or social media,
它不仅在我们没有像以前那样经历那么多新奇感的基础上，加速了我们对时间的感知。短格式无限滚动视频的引入极大地改变了我们这一代人体验时间的方式，与老年人相比，可能仅次于大流行。我们以探索三种时间类型开始这一集：衡量的、社会的和感知的。在当今时代，研究人员现在说还有第四种，那就是时间的数字体验。它完全颠覆了我们所知道的关于时间的一切。随着数字技术发展到我认为每个人都有智能手机或社交媒体的地步，
unless they've made a very distinct choice not to, what we're finding is that perceptions of time are rapidly increasing and our ability to correctly evaluate how much time we've done. We're spend doing things is decreasing as well. An example of this is like, you think that you've only scrolled for five minutes, you've probably scrolled for 15 and we can't tell the difference. You also think that, you know, cooking dinner is probably going to take an hour and Uber eats is going to take 25 minutes, but it's actually the reverse. Our sense of how long things take has just been flipped. Technology has made a lot of things a lot more efficient. Online shopping makes it so that, you know, we don't have to go all the way to the store to get
除非他们做出了非常明确的选择不这样做，否则我们发现对时间的感知正在迅速增加，我们正确评估我们做事情花费了多少时间的能力也在下降。这方面的一个例子是，你认为你只刷了五分钟，你可能刷了15分钟，我们无法分辨区别。你还认为，你知道，做晚饭可能需要一个小时，Uber Eats需要25分钟，但实际上恰恰相反。我们对事情需要多长时间的感觉刚刚被颠覆。技术使很多事情变得更加高效。在线购物意味着，你知道，我们不必一直去商店买
what we need. Delivery services mean that, you know, you don't have to go out for food or you don't have to go out to the groceries, you don't have to go out to buy clothes, you don't have to go out to really do anything. There's online health services, there's online entertainment, you know, everything that would require you to leave the house, even for like appointments. Like it can now all be done online and it's apparently more convenient. it. When you decide even then that you do want to go and, you know, do a chore in real life, or go out to a restaurant or anything, like deciding where to go, deciding how to get there, deciding what you're going to order. Like there's an app for everything. You pick a restaurant, Google Maps is already finding you the most convenient pathway. You get there, the reviews are
我们需要的东西。送货服务意味着，你知道，你不必出去吃饭，或者你不必出去买杂货，你不必出去买衣服，你不必出去做任何事情。有在线健康服务，有在线娱乐，你知道，任何需要你离开房子的事情，即使是预约。它现在都可以在线完成，而且显然更方便。即使在那时，当你决定你确实想去，你知道，在现实生活中做家务，或者去餐馆或任何地方，决定去哪里，决定怎么去那里，决定你要点什么。有一个应用程序可以做任何事情。你选择一家餐馆，谷歌地图已经在为你寻找最方便的路径。你到了那里，评论已经
already telling you exactly what's best to order. This lack of friction seems like a good thing in many ways. AI has only made it so much easier, which I feel like if you know me, you know I have many, many opinions on this that we need another episode for. But it can actually waste a lot more time because as soon as you're using your phone for everything, it's also where you're getting a lot of your enjoyment and pleasure from. So you're being pushed back into the same environment, where you get entertainment every time you want to be productive. All of our decisions, all of our time, our whole life revolves around a screen. And that's doing things to our brain. I found this 2023 study where these researchers interviewed some students in France.
在告诉你到底点什么最好。这种缺乏摩擦在许多方面看起来是一件好事。人工智能只会让它变得更容易，我觉得如果你了解我，你就知道我对此有很多很多意见，我们需要另一集来谈。但它实际上会浪费更多的时间，因为一旦你把手机用于所有事情，它也是你获得很多享受和快乐的地方。所以你被推回了同样的环境，每次你想提高效率时，你都会得到娱乐。我们所有的决定，我们所有的时间，我们整个生活都围绕着屏幕。这正在对我们的大脑做些事情。我发现了这项2023年的研究，这些研究人员采访了法国的一些学生。
They were all between the ages of 18 and 29, and they asked them about their relationship to time and their relationship to digital technology, specifically their phones. The study found that intense use of digital media prompted losing the notion of time almost completely during moments of the day and losing a sense of feeling in control. It felt like time was harder to manage. It felt like less was happening in their days. It felt like that time was moving in a way that they couldn't perceive. They were blink and it was like, oh my God, 20 minutes passed. The thing is, like, our phones are fun. It doesn't always feel like a waste in the beginning. It's productive sometimes and there's a major sense of socialization and bonding and it's all excites us and it excites our brain.
他们都在18到29岁之间，他们问他们关于与时间的关系以及与数字技术的关系，特别是他们的手机。研究发现，过度使用数字媒体导致在一天中的某些时刻几乎完全失去了时间概念，并失去了控制感。感觉时间更难管理。感觉日子里发生的事情更少。感觉时间以一种他们无法感知的方式移动。他们眨眼间，就像，天哪，20分钟过去了。问题是，我们的手机很有趣。起初并不总是感觉像浪费。有时它是高效的，并且有一种主要的社交和联系感，它让我们兴奋，它刺激了我们的大脑。
But it also puts us into a mental state called cognitive inertia. This was a concept first labeled by the psychologist William McGarry in the 1960s. And he basically said, if someone is fixated on something and if they are at rest in that thing, it's hard to get them to move or to change because we like to stay the same. We are organisms that like structure and stability. When we are scrolling, it is very hard to pull our brain away from that state if it's having fun. Even if it's not productive, if we are comfortable and this position, it's difficult to move us on from that. We just want to watch one more video.
但它也把我们带入了一种叫做认知惯性的心理状态。这是心理学家威廉·麦加里在20世纪60年代首次标记的一个概念。他基本上说，如果一个人专注于某件事，如果他们在那个事物中处于休息状态，就很难让他们移动或改变，因为我们喜欢保持不变。我们是喜欢结构和稳定性的有机体。当我们滚动时，如果它很有趣，很难把我们的大脑从那种状态中拉出来。即使它不是高效的，如果我们在这个位置感到舒适，很难让我们从那里移动。我们只是想再看一个视频。
We just want five more minutes. Even as we start to feel less and less stimulated, the pool is still there because it takes more friction to move us from doing something to doing another thing than it does if we just kept doing that one thing for this whole time. So also to return to the relationship between novelty and time, we're also seeing so much so quickly. And one would think that since we are constantly seeing new things online, you know, when you scroll, like, you literally could see somebody who's in Paris, somebody who's just hiked, climbed Mount Everest, like somebody who's just had a baby and somebody who's, you could literally find a video of somebody in every single corner of the world. Why, if this is novel, is this not making time feel like it's slowing down, right? Because that's what we explored before. Novel experiences make time go slower.
我们只是想再多待五分钟。即使我们开始感到越来越少的刺激，这种吸引力依然存在，因为从做一件事到做另一件事所需要的摩擦力，比我们一直做那件事所需要的摩擦力要大。所以回到新奇感和时间之间的关系，我们也看到这么多东西过得这么快。人们会认为，既然我们不断地在网上看到新事物，你知道，当你滚动时，你字面上可以看到一个在巴黎的人，一个刚刚徒步、爬上珠穆朗玛峰的人，像一个刚刚生了孩子的人，你可以字面上找到一个在世界每一个角落的人的视频。为什么，如果这是新奇的，这没有让时间感觉慢下来，对吧？因为这就是我们之前探索的。新奇的经历让时间过得更慢。
if all we're getting is like insane levels of novelty from our phone, why is that not happening? Well, the answer to this question also has something to do with what we talked about earlier, which is memory. Memory is so critical here. In order for a memory to be made, any memory in your brain, anybody's brain, your mind needs to process that it happened in the first place. Very simple, right? But that's critical for consolidation. Something needs to feel distinct, and it has to feel like it happened for us to remember. it. When the span of a novel event is being fit into spaces of seconds or less, you know, the time it takes to scroll between two or three videos on TikTok, your brain just has a hard time deciphering
如果我们从手机上得到的只是疯狂的新奇感，为什么那种感觉没有发生呢？嗯，这个问题的答案也与我们之前谈到的记忆有关。记忆在这里至关重要。为了形成记忆，大脑中的任何记忆，任何人的大脑，你的思维都需要先处理它发生了这件事。很简单，对吧？但这对于巩固记忆至关重要。某件事需要感觉独特，并且必须感觉它确实发生了，我们才能记住它。当一个新奇事件的跨度被压缩到几秒钟甚至更短的时间内，你知道，也就是在TikTok上滚动浏览两三个视频所需的时间，你的大脑就很难分辨
between one thing and the next. There is actually too much going on. There is too much being pumped into your brain for your mind to actually find out or figure out or see what is worth consolidating. And so it processes it all as one big event. When you're on your phone, that's one big kind of almost nothing event because there wasn't enough distinctness for your brain to devote a whole memory to it. The other thing that Constance scrolling does is it makes it harder to consolidate memories that happen before and after you've been on your screen. Now this specifically is a phenomenon called proactive interference and it's when experiences outside of a memory interfere with that memory being processed.
一件事和下一件事之间的区别。实际上发生的事情太多了。输入你大脑的信息太多了，以至于你的思维无法真正发现、弄清楚或看出什么值得巩固。因此，它把这一切都处理为一个大事件。当你玩手机时，那是一个几乎什么都没发生的大事件，因为没有足够的独特性让你的大脑为它投入全部记忆。持续滚动浏览的另一个作用是，它让你更难巩固在你使用屏幕之前和之后发生的记忆。现在，这特别是一种被称为主动干扰的现象，即记忆之外的经历干扰了该记忆的处理。
I know that sounds a bit complicated, but with the short form content specifically, your brain feels so overhyped and so stimulated so quickly, it is like we are so in on this, whatever just happened, we don't have time to solidify that. We don't have time to recognize that that was real life.
我知道这听起来有点复杂，但特别是对于短视频内容，你的大脑感觉太兴奋、太快受到刺激了，就像我们对刚刚发生的任何事情都太投入了，我们没有时间去巩固它。我们没有时间去意识到那是现实生活。
And then whatever happens afterwards, we're so overwhelmed by what we just saw and all this stuff that we can't consolidate anything that happens afterwards. for a couple of minutes either. So all this time around these experience around your screen time is erased. You know, whilst our bodies naturally are going to make less memories as we age, research is showing that because of our phones, that's happening in a much faster rate, the digital factor is the biggest factor in what is speeding up your sense of time.
然后无论之后发生什么，我们都被刚刚看到的东西和所有这些东西淹没了，以至于我们在接下来的几分钟内也无法巩固任何事情。所以，围绕你屏幕时间的这些经历的所有时间都被抹去了。你知道，虽然随着年龄的增长，我们的身体自然会产生更少的记忆，但研究表明，由于手机的原因，这种情况发生的速度要快得多，数字因素是加速你时间感的最主要因素。
There was a study conducted in Munich literally last month that concluded heavy digital media use can produce the same type of time compression in people in their 20s and 30s that people used to experience in their 60s. Your sense of time is the same as somebody who is 60. And that is so scary to think about because when you are hopefully 60, what happens then? Like what is your perception of time going to be like then? Our life expectancy is also increasing year after year, but does that matter if our experience of time is decreasing? Like, does it really matter? It's almost like we've hit this peak and now we're going back. I think that's a question that's much bigger than psychology, so we're not going to answer it on
慕尼黑上个月进行了一项研究，得出的结论是，大量的数字媒体使用可以在20多岁和30多岁的人群中产生与60多岁的人过去所经历的相同类型的时间压缩。你的时间感和60岁的人一样。想到这一点非常可怕，因为当你到了60岁时，会发生什么呢？比如那时你对时间的感知会是什么样？我们的预期寿命也在逐年增加，但如果我们的时间体验在减少，那还有意义吗？比如，这真的重要吗？这几乎就像我们已经达到了顶峰，现在正在走下坡路。我认为这是一个比心理学大得多的问题，所以我们不会在
this episode, but if you want to avoid that happening to you, we can talk about that. And I'm going to give you a little bit of a guide as to what exactly we're going to do to kind of pause this process and to get time and us back on the same level so that we can have, you know, important memories so that we can feel like our time here is filled with good stuff and is distinct and is something that we have control over. The obvious and the predictable answer as well, I will admit, is to just simply control digital media use or eliminate it altogether. Get off our phones. You know, if these pockets of lost or wasted time are freed up by taking us away from our screens, we can put that time to better use. We can have more novel
这一集中回答它，但如果你想避免这种情况发生在你身上，我们可以谈谈。我将为你提供一个小指南，说明我们到底要做什么来暂停这个过程，让时间和我们回到同一个水平，这样我们就可以拥有，你知道，重要的记忆，这样我们就可以感觉我们在此时此地的时光是充实的、独特的，并且是我们能够掌控的。我承认，显而易见且可预测的答案就是简单地控制数字媒体的使用或完全消除它。放下手机。你知道，如果通过让我们远离屏幕来腾出这些丢失或浪费的时间，我们可以更好地利用这些时间。我们可以有更多新奇的
experiences in the real world. That sounds very straightforward. That sounds very uncomplicated. It's definitely easier said than done. Many aspects of digital media, we know this, are designed to hook people. They are designed to keep them on a very short attention span leash. And your level of willpower has very little say in the matter. Many digital media developers, you know, build their platforms with the help of neuroscientists, psychologists, psychologists, psychiatrists, they designed them to be inherently appealing despite your self-control. And now that we're all hooked, taking a step back means exiting a world where everybody else resides, meaning that you are going to have to pay a large social cost for your choice.
在现实世界中的体验。这听起来非常直截了当。这听起来非常简单。这绝对是说起来容易做起来难。我们知道，数字媒体的许多方面都是为了吸引人们而设计的。它们旨在将人们保持在非常短的注意力链条上。而你的意志力在这一点上几乎没有发言权。许多数字媒体开发者，你知道，在神经科学家、心理学家、精神病学家的帮助下构建他们的平台，他们设计这些平台是为了在你不自控的情况下具有内在的吸引力。现在我们都上瘾了，退后一步意味着要离开每个人都居住的世界，这意味着你将不得不为你的选择付出巨大的社会代价。
And that's a really hard decision to make. I've done so many episodes on this, so many episodes on how to control your digital media usage. We just did one on R.R.O. Phones Killing Intimacy. We did one earlier this year on how to rebuild your attention span that talks about it a lot. So I'm just, I'm not going to go really, really deep into it. But I think the overall strategy for you right now, if your screen time is high, if you're realizing it's changing your perception of time, is really to just do three things. And I'm going to say three things, but they contain a lot. The three things, though, are have an awareness of your internal dissonance. Basically, if you want to
这是一个非常艰难的决定。我已经做了很多关于这个话题的节目，很多关于如何控制数字媒体使用的节目。我们刚刚做了一期关于“手机正在扼杀亲密关系”的节目。我们今年早些时候做了一期关于如何重建注意力广度的节目，里面谈了很多。所以我不会深入探讨它。但我认为如果你现在的屏幕时间很高，如果你意识到它正在改变你对时间的感知，那么你现在的总体策略就是做三件事。我会说三件事，但它们包含了很多内容。这三件事是：意识到你的内在失调。基本上，如果你想
control your screen time, notice that you are unhappy about your screen time and notice that you keep doing it anyway. Ignolage the dissonance. Acknowledge, hey, I would actually like to get better here. I want to add time back into my life, but I can't. Why is that? Then you get testing. This is the second point. Testing the alternative reality or the second reality, as we sometimes call it. So trialing out periods where you don't use social media or your phone is left at home while you go out with your friends and really paying attention to if you feel better. Your brain, your brain,
控制你的屏幕时间，注意到你对自己的屏幕时间不满意，并注意到你仍然在继续这样做。承认这种失调。承认，嘿，我其实想在这里做得更好。我想把时间加回我的生活中，但我做不到。为什么会这样？然后你进行测试。这是第二点。测试替代现实或第二现实，正如我们有时所说的那样。所以尝试一些你不使用社交媒体的时期，或者当你和朋友出去时把手机留在家里，并真正注意你是否感觉更好。你的大脑，你的大脑，
body needs evidence that this alternative is not a threat, there's actually a lot of benefit and joy to not being on your phone as much. And then three, promising yourself slow implementation. You know this works, you know you feel better. Now just try one strategy at a time to curtail your phone use until that one sticks. So whether it's app blockers, whether it's deleting social media at home, whether it's time limits, anything like that, one at a time. I will say one of my friends has this unbelievably effective strategy that I don't think anything can beat, where she gets her friends to set her screen time password for her. And she has made us like square up and down that we will not tell her what it is at all. We said it for her one night when we were like out
身体需要证据证明这种替代方案不是威胁，不怎么玩手机实际上有很多好处和乐趣。然后第三，承诺自己缓慢实施。你知道这有效，你知道你感觉更好。现在只需一次尝试一个策略来减少你的手机使用，直到那个策略坚持下来。所以无论是应用程序拦截器，还是在家里删除社交媒体，还是时间限制，任何类似的东西，一次一个。我会说我的一个朋友有一个令人难以置信的有效策略，我认为没有什么能比得上，她让她的朋友为她设置屏幕时间密码。她让我们发誓绝对不会告诉她密码是什么。我们在一个晚上我们出去的时候为她设置了它
and we were out drinking. I don't even think we know what it is. And that way like when she wants like she's not getting through. It's actually she's basically locked herself out of being able to break a promise to herself because she doesn't know the password. She doesn't know it. And there have been times, especially at the beginning where she'd be like, does anybody remember it? Like, please. But at that stage, like when she was begging us and asking us, it's like, well, suddenly she was talking to us. Suddenly she was in back, back to where we were, you know, back in this like social environment, back having experiences with something other than a screen or other than a phone. that's how you kind of, it's such a basic way of describing how to break a screen addiction.
我们出去喝酒的时候。我甚至不认为我们知道它是什么。这样一来，当她想要的时候，她就无法通过。实际上，她基本上把自己锁在外面，无法违背对自己的承诺，因为她不知道密码。她不知道。有几次，特别是在开始的时候，她会说，有人记得吗？拜托。但在那个阶段，当她乞求我们并询问我们时，突然间她就在和我们说话了。突然间她又回到了我们所在的地方，你知道，回到了这种社交环境中，回到了除了屏幕或手机之外还有其他体验的状态。这就是你如何描述如何打破手机成瘾的一种非常基本的方式。
As I said, we have more, much better episodes on it. But the second crucial thing for getting time back in your life and feeling like you have more time to live and to do things is that novelty principle and that novelty aspect. We're going to talk about that and so much more because it deserves its whole section of this episode after this short break. Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers, now at McDonald's. Made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details of McDonald's.cai at participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec.
正如我所说，我们有更多、更好的相关节目。但让你生活中找回时间并感觉你有更多时间去生活和做事情的第二个关键点是那个新奇原则和新奇方面。我们将在这次短暂的休息后讨论这一点以及更多内容，因为它值得这一集的整个部分。红牛龙莓和热带莓能量饮料，现在在麦当劳有售。由冷冻干燥水果和爆发的电感风味制成。全新的红牛能量饮料，现在在麦当劳。本产品可能不适合你。咖啡因含量高，详情请见麦当劳网站，在参与活动的加拿大餐厅有售，魁北克除外。
When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how I, other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started to
我14岁时被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我活了下来，我一生都在探索我和其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的事情中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边传来那个低沉、嘲弄的声音说，闭嘴，什么都别说。每周，我都与经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始感觉到床尾有人，我就开始
It's screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random. dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by
尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。但这些不是关于他们被夺走了什么的故事。这些是关于为了活下来需要付出什么的故事。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时等下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙提议让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为
myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people and they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
这是一个罕见的空间，我可以说是，而不需要先问任何人。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性来交换怜悯。每次我试图独处时，我都会遇到人，他们会说，你对我们笑了。这里没多少人笑。当你独处时，你最能接受世界的本来面目，而不是关于它的谎言。这可以是一个你突破极限、改变主意或唤醒新自我的时间。所以无论你是独自旅行的老手，还是太紧张而不敢预订第一次旅行，我希望你在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts上收听《Solita》，
or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your for you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast. The weekly That's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed.
或者任何你获取播客的地方。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《Prose Society》，每周播客。每周，这既是读书俱乐部，又是思想女儿、流行文化痴迷者和任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》值得同等程度讨论的人的群聊。我是伊莱·拉洛，每周我们都在连接书籍、互联网和每个人都无法停止谈论的对话之间的点。我得查查这个故事。我着迷了。
From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages, inside compelling characters, and that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages.
从畅销书作家和你最喜欢的读书博主到最新的流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可以谈论的。这就像如果你能把一些真实的信息隐藏在引人入胜的角色中，那就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度解析、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢思考太多的读者社区，你都来对地方了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Prose Society》。书页间见。
Hey, what's up? I'm Tony Gonzalez. And I'm October Gonzalez, but you can call me Toby. We want you to join us on our new podcast, No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez. We get real about marriage, parenthood, sex, divorce, and all the nitty-gritty stuff we all think about, but just don't say out loud. I hate that job. You're probably just going to meet with some rich guy, and he's going to whisk you away, and I'll never see you again. Wow. Well, this is awkward.
嘿，你好吗？我是托尼·冈萨雷斯。我是奥克托芭·冈萨雷斯，但你可以叫我托比。我们希望你加入我们的新播客《No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez》。我们真实地谈论婚姻、为人父母、性、离婚以及我们都想过但只是没有大声说出来的所有琐碎事情。我讨厌那份工作。你可能只是去见某个有钱人，他会把你带走，我就再也见不到你了。哇。好吧，这很尴尬。
Would you say a D-less actor? D? I don't even know. There's such thing as D. No, no, no. I mean, like... Can't even get on the C-list? Like, I'm not even an average.
你会说一个D级演员吗？D？我甚至不知道。有D级这种东西吗？不，不，不。我的意思是，像……连C级都进不去？就像，我甚至不是平均水平。
I'm not even passing. I'm failing. Listen to No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez, part of My Culture, Podcast, network, available on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. If you want time to feel slower and more expansive, you've just got to give your mind some fresh experiences to hold on to. You need to think about all the ways that you can introduce novelty back into your life. And now, this doesn't need to be trying out new hobbies every single week or doing massive things like I'm going to go on an overseas holiday once every three months.
我甚至没有及格。我失败了。收听《No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez》，这是My Culture播客网络的一部分，可在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。如果你想让时间感觉更慢、更广阔，你只需要给你的思维一些新鲜的体验来抓住。你需要考虑所有你可以将新奇感带回生活的方法。现在，这不需要每周尝试新爱好或做像每三个月去一次海外度假这样的大事。
All you need to do is just microdose novelty more regularly. If you drink coffee, you can do this. Literally switch up your flavor every month, switch up your brand every month. Take the other route to work that you always avoid because it's five more minutes. Try and find more creative routes to work every single day. Try not to get lunch or dinner at the same place twice and literally just do more stuff. I know it's really hard. I know we're pretty tired all the time. I personally just really want to be at home as well. Constantly, I'm tired. But you will have time for that when there's literally nothing else you can do. You know what will help you more than anything else to do this is your friends, I will say. Firstly, yes, definitely acknowledging like at some point I'm not going to be
你所要做的只是更经常地微量摄入新奇感。如果你喝咖啡，你可以这样做。字面上每个月换一种口味，每个月换一个品牌。走你总是避免的那条去上班的路，因为它多花五分钟。每天尝试寻找更多去上班的创意路线。尽量不要在同一个地方吃两次午餐或晚餐，字面上只是做更多的事情。我知道这真的很难。我知道我们一直都很累。我个人也真的只想待在家里。不断地，我很累。但当字面上没有其他事情可做时，你会有时间做那个。你知道什么会比任何其他事情更能帮助你做到这一点吗？是你的朋友，我会说。首先，是的，绝对要承认，在某个时候我不会
able to do anything else other than rest, so I may as well get out. But the most invaluable tip for getting more out of life is just being around people whose natural inclination is just to do things. My natural set point is to be a home body. But the moment I made friends with people who bought tickets to stuff, who wanted to go out on Thursday night, who wanted to do like the weird art class or out of the house every day, like my life got so much bigger thanks to them. And I know. that's because of this very critical psychological principle that is known as behavioral contagion. When people we know or people we admire do things, we unconsciously feel the need to do similar things. This is positive peer pressure and being around people who are already doing stuff
能够做除了休息之外的任何事情，所以我不如出去。但从生活中获得更多收获的最宝贵的建议就是和那些天生倾向于做事情的人在一起。我天生的设定点是做一个宅男/宅女。但当我开始和那些买票去看东西、想在周四晚上出去、想做奇怪的艺术课或每天都出门的朋友在一起时，我的生活因为他们而变得大得多。我知道这是因为这个非常关键的心理学原则，被称为行为传染。当我们认识的人或我们钦佩的人做某事时，我们会下意识地感到需要做类似的事情。这是积极的同伴压力，和已经在做事情的人在一起
is the easiest way to kind of make it come about. There's a very famous idea that we are the average of the five closest people that we surround ourselves with. Very famous. I feel like there's been books written about this, there's been academic articles written about this. And although the idea first came from somebody who wasn't in the psychology space, he was actually an entrepreneur, and he kind of mainly talked about this in like a business networking sense, the science does still support it from a lifestyle, from a psychology sense, a psychology perspective, you are the five closest people that you surround yourself with. So if you want time to slow down and you want time to expand around you, be around people
是让它发生的最简单方法。有一个非常著名的观点，即我们是我们周围最亲密的五个人的平均值。非常著名。我觉得已经有关于此的书籍，也有关于此的学术文章。虽然这个想法最初来自一个不在心理学领域的人，他实际上是一个企业家，他主要是在商业社交意义上谈论这个，但科学确实从生活方式、心理学意义、心理学角度支持它，你就是你周围最亲密的五个人。所以如果你想让时间慢下来，你想让时间在你周围扩展，那就和那些
who are going to make that happen. Be around people who are going to give you more experiences the way you've given them more experiences. Cultivate connections. Go to things even when you just really, really would rather not. Like I said, there will come a time when you wish that you had the social freedom and the energy and the physical ability to do what you could do right now.
会使之发生的人在一起。和那些会给你更多体验的人在一起，就像你给他们更多体验一样。培养联系。即使在你真的、真的宁愿不去的时候也要去参加活动。就像我说的，总有一天你会希望你有社交自由、精力和身体能力去做你现在能做的事情。
So just take advantage of it. You know, in our 20s, you may not have heaps of money to create novelty, but you do have heaps of time. And, you know, you have more time than you ever will. right at this point to explore and to be around your friends and to deepen relationships and to just do crazy shit, this is when you need to be doing it. Basically, newness in your life doesn't have to be self-generated. That's just what I'm trying to say. It can be collective. It can be borrowed. And that is honestly one of the most underrated ways that you can speed up your rate of memory
所以利用它吧。你知道，在我们20多岁的时候，你可能没有大量的钱来创造新奇感，但你有大量的时间。而且，你知道，你拥有的时间比你以后任何时候都多。就在这一点上，去探索，和你的朋友在一起，加深关系，做一些疯狂的事情，这就是你需要做的时候。基本上，你生活中的新鲜感不必是自我生成的。这就是我想说的。它可以是集体的。它可以是借来的。老实说，这是你可以加快记忆形成速度的最被低估的方法之一
making without really having to force yourself to do anything and therefore slow down your perception of time so that it feels like you have lived more life in your years than it seems. I think the final thing that expands our sense of time, especially from a memory perspective, which we know is critical, is just ensuring that you are documenting your life in some way beyond the screen. I've spoken about this before, but when I was younger, I was obsessed. I was obsessed with this idea of storing my memories and not letting anything slip me by. And I was very worried I was going to get Alzheimer's and I would keep these massive photo albums and these diaries. and these scrapbooks. And I used to do this thing called the one second a day diary. Hands up if you also did this. But for five years straight, I recorded one second of my day every single day. I was so obsessive about it. I think I started in high school. I went all the way up to my third year of uni.
而不需要真正强迫自己做任何事情，从而减慢你对时间的感知，这样感觉你在这几年里活得比看起来更多。我认为最后一件扩展我们时间感的事情，特别是从记忆的角度来看，我们知道这是至关重要的，就是确保你以某种方式记录你的生活，而不仅仅是在屏幕上。我以前说过这个，但我年轻的时候，我很着迷。我着迷于存储我的记忆并不让任何事情溜走的想法。我非常担心我会得阿尔茨海默病，我会保留这些巨大的相册和日记。还有这些剪贴簿。我过去常做一件叫做“一天一秒”日记的事情。如果你也这样做过，请举手。但连续五年，我每天都记录我一天中的一秒钟。我对此非常着迷。我想我是从高中开始的。我一直记录到大学三年级。
And I look back at that and I'm like, I am so grateful I did that. I now have my own documentary of my life that I made from that time. And I went back and watched it when I was like thinking about. this episode and you really don't realize how young you really were, but also how much time you have until you see the past in this romantic sense. And until you see all these moments captured that in the moment you just didn't have time to appreciate. And now that they are history, they just feel so much more full and so much more important. You know, when I watch those back, I think about time differently. I see how much of it I have had and how much of it I will have and how much good stuff has happened to me and it's such a gift from my past self. I'm so grateful that she did that. I don't think I knew
我回顾那段时光，我想，我非常感激我那样做了。我现在拥有我从那个时期制作的关于我生活的纪录片。当我想到这一集时，我回去看了它，你真的没有意识到你当时有多年轻，但当你以这种浪漫的感觉看到过去时，你也没有意识到你拥有多少时间。直到你看到所有这些在当时你只是没有时间去欣赏的瞬间被捕捉下来。现在它们成为了历史，它们感觉更加充实、更加重要。你知道，当我回看那些时，我对时间的思考方式不同了。我看到我拥有了多少时间，我将拥有多少时间，发生了多少好事，这是我过去的自己给我的礼物。我非常感激她那样做了。我不认为我知道
how important it was going to be. I think maybe I had some idea. I think it was more of a neurotic compulsion. But I realize now the importance of documenting your life in whatever way is easiest for you. And I found that the times in my life that go by the fastest is when I'm not doing that. So a journal, a junk scrapbook, a picture a day, a video a day, a podcast, it all grounds you. Very seriously, it grounds you. And it grounds you in a way that Instagram stories or Instagram posts, I just don't think can't. I don't think they bring the same joy as creating something offline that you have documented just for you that has no social validation component, that isn't reliant on a platform being up and isn't reliant on, you know, something working beyond you to
它会变得多么重要。我想也许我有一些想法。我想这更多是一种神经质的强迫。但我现在意识到以任何对你来说最简单的方式记录你的生活的重要性。我发现我生活中过得最快的时间是我没有这样做的时候。所以日记、垃圾剪贴簿、一天一张照片、一天一个视频、播客，这一切都会让你脚踏实地。非常严肃地说，它让你脚踏实地。它让你脚踏实地的方式是Instagram故事或Instagram帖子无法做到的。我不认为它们能带来像在离线状态下创造一些你专门为你记录的东西那样的快乐，它没有社会验证成分，不依赖于平台的运行，也不依赖于，你知道，超越你的东西来
have. Like, Atomic bomb goes off. You'll still have your photo albums. And I think that that's valuable in itself, and it helps you prolong a sense of time in your life. I just think time flies when we lose our appreciation for it. And that's why in our 20s in particular, things do reach this point where they really start to feel like they're speeding up. You know, when we were young, everything felt special, everything felt new, and now things feel very routine and old. There is still so much that's going to happen to you, and there's so much to see and so much to experience, You just have to prioritize it. It's a lot easier said than done considering busy schedules and considering money and considering
拥有。比如，原子弹爆炸了。你仍然会有你的相册。我认为这本身就很有价值，它有助于你延长生活中的时间感。我只是认为当我们失去对时间的欣赏时，时间就会飞逝。这就是为什么特别是在我们20多岁时，事情确实到了这一点，它们真的开始感觉在加速。你知道，当我们年轻时，一切都感觉很特别，一切都感觉很新鲜，而现在事情感觉非常例行公事和陈旧。仍然有很多事情会发生在你身上，有很多东西要看，有很多东西要体验，你只需要优先考虑它。考虑到繁忙的日程、金钱和
practicality. But even just a day or an afternoon in your week where you promise to make something special and novel and do something important for yourself is going to elongate your week, which is going to elongate your years, which is going to elongate your life. And I think I want to end this episode with one final thought that I have quite a lot. And I don't even know if this is relevant or helpful. So apologies if it's not, but this might get dark. But any time I feel like time is running out for me in my 20s,
实用性，这说起来容易做起来难。但即使只是你一周中的一天或一个下午，你承诺让某件事变得特别和新奇，并为自己做一些重要的事情，也会拉长你的一周，这将拉长你的年份，这将拉长你的生命。我想用我经常有的一个最终想法来结束这一集。我甚至不知道这是否相关或有帮助。所以如果不是，请见谅，但这可能会变得沉重。但每当我感觉我在20多岁时时间快用完时，
I picture the thousands of people who have died at the exact age I am right now. You know, there is somebody who died at 26 years and 74 days old. And tomorrow, God willing, I get to live to be 26 and 75 days. What they wouldn't give for that extra day. what a privilege. And it makes me really, really grateful for any time I get. And it puts all those other smaller problems into perspective. It's very hard to be productive and to want to work or do things that you don't think are important when you remember that the day you're having right now was somebody's last day on earth. And maybe that's the antidote for time flying. Like it's gratitude.
我就会想象成千上万在和我现在完全相同的年龄去世的人。你知道，有人在26岁74天时去世了。明天，上帝保佑，我能活到26岁75天。他们为了那额外的一天会付出什么呢？多么荣幸。这让我对我得到的任何时间都感到非常、非常感激。它把所有那些其他较小的问题都放在了正确的视角下。当你记住你现在度过的一天是某人在地球上的最后一天时，很难保持高效，很难想要工作或做你认为不重要的事情。也许这就是时间飞逝的解药。就像它是感恩。
Gratitude is the antidote. Gratitude for what you have and the fact that you still get to wake up and experience new things every single day. And what a blessing that is is the antidote to feeling like you are running out of time. Okay, I'm going to stop rambling here. And I'm going to give you the quick summary about episode before this turns into more of a philosophy podcast. Then it already is. We're going to turn it back into a psychology one. Basically, this experience that you are having right now of time getting faster is really normal with age. It's super normal. It comes down to a reduction and novel experiences. It comes down to how our brain processes the passing of time. It comes down to the role of memory. But it's also being exacerbated by our technology usage. If you want to add
感恩是解药。对你所拥有的感恩，以及你仍然可以每天醒来并体验新事物的事实。这是多么大的福气，是感觉你时间不够用的解药。好吧，我要在这里停止胡言乱语了。在这一集变成比它已经是的哲学播客之前，我要给你一个快速总结。我们要把它变回心理学播客。基本上，你现在正在经历的时间变快的感觉在年龄增长时是非常正常的。这超级正常。它归结为新奇体验的减少。它归结为我们的大脑如何处理时间的流逝。它归结为记忆的作用。但它也正在被我们的技术使用所加剧。如果你想增加
more years back into your life, put down your phone and live. Go and do stuff. Go camping with your friends. Really challenge yourself to try new things, try new foods, see people, go to events, buy tickets to stuff, document what feels important. When you do that, time is going to feel less restrictive. It's going to feel more expansive. And that's the best advice I have for you. So I really do hope that you enjoyed this episode. I also hope it wasn't too existential.
更多的时间回到你的生活中，放下手机去生活。去和朋友做点事情。去露营。真正挑战自己去尝试新事物，尝试新食物，见人，去参加活动，买票去看东西，记录下感觉重要的事情。当你这样做时，时间会感觉不那么受限制。它会感觉更广阔。这就是我给你的最好的建议。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我也希望它没有太存在主义。
Apologies if it was. If you want to watch more full episodes like this, you can do so on Netflix. And if you want the transcript versions of this very episode, direct to your inbox so you can read whilst you listen or you want to know where we get the studies from, you can subscribe to us on Substack, where I also share more research papers and academic science stuff in our study of the week series. It's such a fun place to be. I'm really enjoying it. I feel like I'm posting more there than anywhere else at the moment. So please go and follow us. I also want to say a huge thank you to our summer intern, Paola, who pitched this episode to me, who helped with the research.
如果太沉重了，请见谅。如果你想观看更多像这样的完整剧集，你可以在Netflix上观看。如果你想要这一集的文字记录版本，直接发送到你的收件箱，这样你就可以在听的时候阅读，或者你想知道我们从哪里获得研究，你可以在Substack上订阅我们，在那里我也在我们的“每周研究”系列中分享更多的研究论文和学术科学内容。这是一个非常有趣的地方。我真的很喜欢它。我觉得我目前在那里发布的内容比任何地方都多。所以请去关注我们。我也想对我们的暑期实习生保拉表示巨大的感谢，她向我推荐了这一集，并帮助进行了研究。
she spent all summer with us in London on an internship from Brown and she was just such a delight. She was amazing. So, Paola, if you are listening, if you're watching, we miss you already and we are so, so proud of you and we hope that you have the most successful, wonderful life and thank you for contributing to this episode. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We really hope you enjoyed and we will talk very, very soon. new podcast Solita. We share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours
她整个夏天都在伦敦和我们一起实习，来自布朗大学，她真是太令人愉快了。她太棒了。所以，保拉，如果你在听，如果你在看，我们已经想念你了，我们为你感到非常、非常骄傲，我们希望你拥有最成功、最美好的生活，感谢你为这一集做出的贡献。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们真的希望你喜欢，我们很快就会再谈。新播客《Solita》。我们分享女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时
for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them.
等下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙提议让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以说是，而不需要先问任何人。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性来交换怜悯。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Solita》。我在囚禁中幸存了九个月，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的事情中幸存下来的。
I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the I Heart Radio, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home.
我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都与经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起，被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。这些是关于为了活下来需要付出什么的故事。在I Heart Radio、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。
Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
《Pro Society》是一个每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，又是群聊，适合任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》值得同等程度讨论的人。每周，我们都在连接书籍、互联网和流行文化与你最喜欢的作家、读书博主以及大量过度思考的观点。是的，我着迷了。我着迷了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Pro Society》。
Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecology at the Adria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the I-Heart Radio app,
欢迎来到《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特博士，纽约市阿德里亚健康研究所女性健康与妇科系主任。我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，并直接为你带来关于中年女性健康的重要信息。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。即使它是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它呢？在I-Heart Radio应用程序上收听伊丽莎白·波因特博士的《解码女性健康》，
Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. What up? This Jay Valentine, co-host of the R&B Money Podcasts alongside my brother, R&B legend, Tank. Together, we've built a space for artists, executives, and fans of R&B music to reminisce and tell the real stories behind the music. I have no money. I was hood famous. They think you're going to get everybody out. We lived in a project.
Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。你好吗？我是杰伊·瓦伦丁，R&B金钱播客的联合主持人，和我兄弟，R&B传奇人物Tank一起。我们一起为R&B音乐的艺术家、高管和粉丝建立了一个空间，让他们回忆并讲述音乐背后的真实故事。我没钱。我曾经在街区很有名。他们以为你会把每个人都带出来。我们住在廉租房里。
Real love came out. They're hearing the music, and we had nothing. From Smokey Robinson to Mary J. Blige, B2K to Jill Scott. If you're a super dedicated R&B fan, this is where you belong. Listen to R&B money from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Real Love》发行了。他们听到了音乐，而我们一无所有。从斯莫基·罗宾逊到玛丽·J·布莱姬，从B2K到吉尔·斯科特。如果你是一个超级忠实的R&B粉丝，这就是你所属的地方。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《R&B Money》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来发表评论。